很多人問我
為什麼你一進場就知道這個盤是有沒有戲
我都笑著說這就叫盤桿
你一定聽過盤桿
但沒人真正說得清楚什麼是盤桿
今天我就來講清楚什麼是盤桿
盤桿為什麼這麼重要
還有最關鍵的
要怎麼訓練出屬於你的盤桿
影片最後我會送你一份
我自己整理的三週盤桿訓練計畫
這是我實戰練出來的方法
看完保證能用一定要看到最後
大家好 我是Moka
我專職當充8年了
有過5年的教學經驗
帶過3000多位學員
首先,什麼是盤感?盤感不是運氣也不是靈感
它是你對市場節奏的直覺反應力
就像老司機開車,看到路況就知道哪輛車要亂開
當沖也是一樣,你看著掛單、名戲、主力、全職
就能感覺出主力想幹嘛
舉個例子,有時候你看到隔票掛單厚厚的感覺很強
價格卻推不動
盤感好的交易者會立刻知道
這是假的,可能有人在出貨
這種感覺就是盤感
它不是猜測,而是對市場節奏的驚艷察覺
那盤感為什麼重要呢?
因為它會從三個地方影響你的獲利
第一個 反應速度
市場變化超快
有時候幾秒就能決定輸贏
盤感好的人不用想太多
看懂了就能做動作
慢一拍就差那一根K棒的假差
第二個 風險控制
盤感不是讓你每次都猜對
而是讓你能更早知道自己錯了
盤感好的人會提早撤退
盤感差的人永遠等停
準備打才後悶
第三個 穩定情緒
有盤感的人看盤就像在開車
知道怎麼順著路試走
沒盤感的人看盤就像在賭博
長就嗨 疊就慌
所以盤感其實是讓你更穩定的關鍵
接著我們來探討盤感怎麼形成
盤感不是天生的
它是經驗和驗證累積出來的我總結出三個來源第一個 你看過夠多盤第二個 你觀察過夠多變化第三 你反覆驗證自己的直覺當你每天觀察盤面 每天記錄 每天檢討
你的大腦就會自動建立市場反應模型
到後來 你會在盤中感受到這個掛檔不太對
這個成交速度怪怪的 那就是盤感啟動了
重點來了 盤感要怎麼訓練
我幫你整理成一個簡單的三週盤感訓練計畫
第一週 練節奏 每天開盤前先寫下你的預測
盤是會強 會弱還是震盪呢
接著挑一到兩檔股票
觀察30分鐘
專注在三件事
第一個 價格的變化速度
第二個 成交量的配合
第三個 買盤節奏是否連續
盤後對照實際走勢
看看自己的感覺準不準
一週下來 你會發現
你稍微能聽到市場的節奏了
第二週 練結構
觀察 誰在主導
每天記錄 買盤 能不能推得動
賣壓是不是固定出現在某個價格
反轉點出現在哪裡
那麼你會開始看到盤面裡的多空拔河
盘感其實是對力量變化的感覺
第三周練反應
最後這周你要練反射
盤中出現掛單異常
成交異常時
先不要動手一一判斷
這是主力試單還是假突破
收盤之後再驗證
久了你會開始提前察覺盤式轉折
當你經歷了這三周的訓練
你會發現盤盤變得有節奏
不容易被情緒影響
能提早察覺主力的意圖
最重要的是你不再猜
而是懂
而這就是我在極短線交易中最看重的能力
如果你想把盤感真正運用到實戰
学会怎么用挂单明细全职去判断多空抓节奏
做出极短线进出
到下方资讯栏点击连结
领取我的实战策略SOP
对你的交易一定有帮助
记住盘感不是天生的
是练出来的
从今天开始给自己三个礼拜
你会发现你看盘的方式完全不一样
我是摩卡也是你的交易教练
我们下次见